no yo creo que la Cumbre Ha logrado
algunos avances alentadores eh Como el
progreso hacia la reasignación de cien
mil millones de dólares en derechos
especiales de giro que son activos
reconocido a nivel internacional creado
por el fondo monetario internacional
también se ha acordado la suspensión de
deudas en caso de desastres climáticos y
un acuerdo para la reestructuración de
la deuda de zambia pero es cierto que
además de esto no hemos visto nada más
concreto ni ambicioso
es una excepción escuchar por ejemplo
que el objetivo de los 100.000 millones
para el cambio climático no se va a
alcanzar este año ahora están diciendo
que es probable que se alcance pero ni
siquiera seguro y es cierto que esto se
debe cumplir cuanto antes porque ya
llevamos dos años de retraso y sabemos
que ahora las necesidades son mucho más
que siempre millones hay algunos
expertos que hablan de cuatro trillones
para descarbonizar la economía global
hay también numerosos llamamientos que
hemos visto hacia un impuesto
internacional que podría ayudar a a todo
toda la lucha contra el cambio climático
y en el resumen final hemos visto que se
va a crear un grupo que va a presentar
una solución probablemente Tan pronto
como para la Cumbre del clima que se va
a celebrar en Kenia en nairobi en
septiembre pero claro necesitamos que
esto ocurra mucho antes
profundizando en este paquete no de cien
mil millones de dólares estamos hablando
de un Punto de partida positivo o queda
corto ante la necesidad de los países
pobres y en vías de desarrollo
bueno el presidente macron merece algo
de crédito porque es cierto que ha
establecido una agenda que finalmente
refleja la escala y pone en el punto de
mira la crisis climática y económica que
está afectando a los países más pobres
pero esa Cumbre básicamente demuestra
que tenemos muy buenas intenciones Hay
buenas intenciones Pero estas buenas
intenciones no van ni alimentar a los
que pasan hambre no va a resolver todos
los desastres climáticos me van a pagar
nuestras deudas solo las todo solo todas
esas promesas no van a resolver la
pobreza extrema cambio climático lo que
necesitamos Es realmente una acción
verdadera Porque si esta acción no llega
Seguiremos preguntándonos si los líderes
mundiales tratarán algún día La amenaza
del cambio climático y la pobreza
extrema con la misma urgencia que las
personas las familias que tienen que
enfrentarse a ellas a diario Guadalupe
cree usted entonces vinculada a lo que
estaba diciendo no que fue una quizás
más marcada por promesas que por
consensos en acciones concretas
Sí hemos visto muchas promesas ha habido
ciertos consensos como
ya le Progreso hace hacia los cien mil
millones de dólares en derechos
especiales de giro hemos visto la
reestructuración de la deuda en zambia
hemos visto esquemáticos pero claro el
problema es que hasta que los países más
ricos y poderosos no están dispuestos a
actuar cuando es necesaria estaremos a
muy lejos de un verdadero nuevo acuerdo
financiero mundial yo creo que la
emisión demostrada a partir de esta
Cumbre debe continuar y debe conducir
acciones mucho más concretas de las que
hemos visto hoy en futuros encuentros
internacionales lo que realmente yo creo
que va a definir si esta Cumbre es un
éxito o un fracaso es la acción real que
vamos a ver después
Guadalupe casas escardó Muchísimas
gracias por este análisis en 24